cars trains planes will all change
fast forward 30 years and the way we
move around
should be different but the co-leader of
the green party says the pandemic
must trigger a review of transport
strategy
the pandemic should put the whole
government transport
uh policy in doubt frankly when you look
at the 27 billion
road building program when you look at
the
freeze on fuel duty i mean these are
things that we should be really
questioning
in the light of the pandemic as well of
course as hs2
but don't you think society just wants
to ping back to the way it was
i think there's a a glimpse of actually
an alternative future a better future
that we can have
decarbonizing transport is crucial if
britain is to reduce its emissions to
net zero by 2050
but even within the green movement
there's division about
how to do it the first phase of hs2
a new high-speed rail link between
london and birmingham
should open in around 10 years time
after that the project will expand
to link the north of england it will all
cost billions
hs2 will offer some of the lowest carbon
emissions per passenger kilometer
the environmental impact of the uk's new
high-speed rail link
hs2 is hotly disputed the green party
says the enormous
infrastructure project isn't needed but
we've spoken to some members of the
greens who formed a support group for
hs2
believing high-speed rail has to be part
of decarbonization
the argument against hs2 is distracting
from
where our real problems lie and those
are in
road building and aviation
we need green infrastructure far more
than we need
new roads opinions are divided but at
grassroots
level activists are taking matters into
their own hands
setting up protest camps along the route
of hs2
trying to get work stopped amongst them
is larch maxi
now above ground he was recently
involved in digging tunnels beneath
houston station
i was down the tunnel for 27 days and
now i'm here you know it's like it's not
that emergency is accelerating so it's
not like there's time to rest you know
for me this is what i'm called to do
the uk has to get to net zero and at
speed
but how that's done is not something
everyone will agree on
even amongst the green movement lisa
holland sky news